live at superhero high where everyone is  busy preparing for the annual hero of  the Year ceremony introducing DC  superhero girls Wonder Woman time to  save the day  Supergirl  Batgirl come on girls it's hero time  Harley Quinn  Kitana and poison ivy and bumblebees  in their very first movie talks lova  come light come on  Eclipse though put down that scepter  darkness attack  this is a school for superheroes not  supervillains you're mine dark opal  you're not getting away  darkness will rule I'm taking you in  that's how we do it DC superhero girls  hero of the year look for it on DVD and  digital HD you're all heroes of the year  and my book  you